[Music]
good evening at welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we live as you may have
noticed in the age of woke capital
they're not just selling products
they're selling something more than that
and you see it everywhere you see in
every movie every commercial every press
release from the diversity division of
your local HR department the message is
always the same companies aren't just
solet's profit seekers are more than
that they have values they have
principles they care they care probably
more than you do once upon a time
corporate America flattered its
customers now they dare you to be as
virtuous as they are but is that real
are they actually virtuous or is all of
this a cynical pose well let you decide
consider this last Friday Daryl Morey
he's the general manager of the Houston
rasca Rockets basketball team sent what
seemed like a non-controversial tweet he
wrote this quote fight for freedom stand
with Hong Kong and quote that's it now
China as you may have seen on television
is now trying to crush Hong Kong and
it's not hard to pick a side China it's
rarely noted but it's true is a racist
ethno state that bans dissent and
murders its political opponents you
think every American would stand with
Hong Kong without even thinking about it
but not the NBA the NBA is on China's
side so amore was forced to delete his
tweet he made in fact lose his job over
this the NBA issued a statement making
it clear that under no circumstance do
they support Hong Kong or human freedom
today basketball Commissioner Adam
Silver emerged to clarify he repeated
the refrain of every person who opposes
free speech sure you're free to say what
you think but you weren't safe from the
consequences the long-held values of the
NBA are to support freedom of expression
daryl morey as the general manager of
the Houston Rockets enjoys that right as
one of our employees what what I also
tried to suggest is I understand that
there are consequences from that
exercise in essence his freedom of
speech
you know we will have to live with those
consequences so it's that hard to say
that we support freedom against the
fascist government of China apparently
it is Steve Kerr's the coach of the
Golden State Warriors on the question of
American politics Korea may have noticed
has no problem speaking his mind he
embraces the hard left social policy
that's suddenly so fashionable among
rich people he doesn't hesitate for
example to demand stricter gun laws for
the rest of us in the words of one
fawning media outlet and there are many
Kerr speaks truth to power all right so
what truths would Steve Kerr ready to
speak to China
well none it turns out not a single
truth to the government of China
choosing between freedom and fascism
turns out to be a really confusing
choice who knows what the right answer
is as Kerr pointed out it's really above
his pay grade our international story
a lot of us don't know what to make of
them this one
it's something I'm reading about just
like everybody is but I kind of come
yeah not gonna comment further it's a
bizarre international story
in other words Steve Kerr's a phony he's
brave when the crowds applaud but when
money is at stake he shuts up and obeys
like the Cowardly little corporate
stooge that he is it's hard to imagine
how a man like that can look himself in
the mirror at night and yet he's not
alone hardly there countless Steve
Kerr's in corporate America all of them
happy to sell out their country and lick
the boots of their Chinese masters for
pay Activision Blizzard that's a major
videogame company just banned a top
player from one of its games because he
gave an interview supporting the
demonstrations in Hong Kong just last
year right outside Washington the hotel
company Marriott fired one of its
employees why for liking a tweet that
recognized Taiwan as a country that's it
that tweet offended China so Marriott
did the bidding of the fascists and
fired him that actually happened this is
common by the way in Hollywood pandering
to China is so common so flagrant that
the show South Park produced an entire
episode mocking it for this movie to
really make money we need to make sure
it clears the Chinese censors you know
we want those Chinese viewers seriously
oh it's okay there's plenty of other
things to talk about with your story how
about what kind of things were you into
when you were younger well we need the
poo okay no no no no that's definitely
off-limits Winnie the poo is illegal in
China because some Chinese student said
he looked like the Chinese president
come on that's ridiculous
maybe ridiculous but South Park was
banned in China after the episode you
just saw you've got to respect its
creators from making the episode anyway
and Comedy Central for airing it most
companies in America were sad to say we
would never do that why you know why
China has one point four billion people
companies want access to that market if
it's a choice between supporting the
United States our country and our people
or getting rich from China it's no
contest from any country companies for
decades neo liberals assured us that it
was our duty to embrace free trade with
China as the rest of us set passively by
they allowed China to steal our
technologies snatch up our properties in
our cities driving up rates
rents decreasing the rates of
homeownership and destroying millions
and millions of course of our
manufacturing jobs making a communist
country vastly richer would be worth it
they assured us because China inevitably
these things were always inevitable
would become much freer and more
democratic as well that was inexorable
because capitalism always leads to
democracy remember that they would not
as they said if they were lying turned
out to be completely false instead of
exporting American freedoms to China a
ruling class instead imported Chinese
authoritarianism here 30 years later
ordinary Americans are poorer wages
haven't moved and all of us are less
free but China and our new liberal elite
are a lot richer it turns out that
fascism whatever you think of it is
pretty good for business that ought to
worry you